who do you think would have more options
a top five percent look Skies with no
money are a top five percent money guy
with no looks
I don't know I think money because the
majority of women are gonna go after
that because they want what comes with
it yeah I disagree with that because
anyone it's not that hard to make women
think you have money but it's definitely
very hard to make women think you're
attractive right okay what if the women
knew they knew like how much each made
they knew how much each made yeah so
like top five percent look I think looks
will still win in today's society
because women don't really need men